how are you just so incredibly male
model looking I always knew that putting
sunscreen on your face was a good thing
I've actually tried for like a decade to
get myself to do this so I fixed that by
using a concept I call watering holes
which is there's a seat I eat in there's
a seat I chill in and there's my office
so there's the only few places that I
actually spend time in if you might have
a massive house or a tiny house doesn't
really matter you only tend to sit in a
few places throughout the day and so
what I do is I use those watering holes
that's where I put stuff so that I get
constant cues to remember to do that
stuff so it's like if I'm having coffee
and I always sit in the same seat and I
want to do it in the morning then I put
it next to my coffee maker or I put it
in the seat that I sit in while drinking
my coffee